trenches bunkers Close Quarter fighting
today the images from the war in Ukraine
resemble the brutal clashes that took
place on the Western Front during World
War One
but as it's counter-offensive gets
underway Ukraine could soon have a new
weapon that experts say could change the
tide of the war by the Year's End
f-16s
in May President Biden said that the U.S
will support a plan to train Ukrainian
Pilots to fly the F-16 today I'm
announcing the next Toronto of U.S
security assistance Ukraine this new
F-16 policy is the first step in a
lengthy process to transform Ukraine's
soviet-style Air Force into a western
one this new joint effort sends a
powerful message about our unity in our
long-term commitment to Ukraine's
self-defense
these Ukrainian Pilots have all of the
talents and the skills to very quickly
hop in an F-16 now you've got a
combination of experienced hardened
tough and dedicated Pilots with very
good Western capability and I think it's
a match in a marriage made in heaven my
blue shoes
here's what a stronger Ukrainian Air
Force could mean for the future of the
war and what Ukrainian Pilots will need
to do in order to become combat ready
foreign
a spokesman for the Ukrainian Air Force
is
Ukraine's Air Force is made up of Soviet
vintage aircraft like the MiG-29
foreign
Russia's Air Force also has Cold War era
Jets but post-soviet modernization has
rejuvenated Russia's Fleet
is
foreign
[Music]
Ukrainian Jets usually are unable to fly
at high altitudes because of their
vulnerability to Russian air defense
missiles
according to leaked classified U.S
military assessments Ukraine's air
defenses which rely mostly on soviet-era
S 300 batteries are running out of
missiles to deter Russian aircraft from
operating in Ukrainian Skies Ukraine has
argued that it needs f-16s
originally developed by a Consortium of
four NATO Nations and the US the F-16
has become a popular option for Many
Nations because of its high performance
and relatively low cost
so there's a lot of questions about why
the F-16 and I think it comes down to a
simple fact of supply and demand John
teichert is retired Air Force Brigadier
General there are almost 5 000 f-16s in
the world they have been widely
proliferated to those that have been
Partners in security cooperation with
the west and a lot of those f-16s are
resident there in Europe in fact there
are eight countries now that are flying
f-16s and five of those countries are
transitioning from the F-16 to the F-35
which means that they now have excess
Supply the F-16 is known as a multi-role
fighter which means it's a combat
aircraft that can perform different
types of missions they have capability
air-to-air against other air adversaries
and they are very flexible and capable
against ground targets that's known as
air-to-ground capability and the
marriage of both of those
characteristics is one that would work
well for Ukraine the Pentagon previously
cited 18 months as the fastest possible
timeline to train Ukrainian Pilots I
don't think the transition for the
Ukrainian Pilots is going to be
difficult at all and I think the best
indicator of how quickly they could do
so is this trial run that we did
recently bringing in a couple of
Ukrainian experienced fighter pilots to
the United States and flying them in
F-16 simulators we found out based on
that trial that it likely would only
take four months or less Russia's Air
Force is far stronger and larger than
Ukraine's Russia doesn't just have more
Air Force personnel combat aircraft and
attack helicopters than Ukraine it also
boasts more advanced aircraft but while
the Russian Air Force is vastly Superior
in numbers and Technology on paper it
has so far failed to win control of
Ukrainian Skies the Russians have a lot
more aircraft than Ukraine is ever going
to have but if you really just look Head
to Head you find that the f-16s would be
likely equal to the capability of 4th
gen aircraft that are being flown by the
Russians in Ukraine the F-16 was also
selected because of its ability to use a
wide array of NATO country weapons the
more different types of weapons it can
use it gives it different combat
capability but it also allows the west
and others that want to contribute
weapons to the fight to be able to use
those weapons on the F-16 in a variety
of ways until recently the White House
was reluctant to supply Ukraine with
f-16s because it was worried that doing
so wrist escalation with Russia and
because of concerns the aircraft would
not survive Russia's formidable air
defenses in May Russia warned that
supplying Ukraine with f-16s would
escalate the war
Biden said he'd received blanket
Assurance from zielinski that the Jets
would not be used to strike targets
inside Russia and thus widen the
wars
it does provide an assurance to Ukraine
that the United States and the West is
going to be tied to them for 20 to 30
years and ultimately it will more than
any other weapon system thus far drag
Ukraine into the Western Way of war and
away from some of the Soviet era
equipment but it remains unclear which
countries would provide Ukraine with the
fighter jets F-16 training for Ukrainian
Pilots is expected to begin within the
next few weeks somewhere in Europe
outside of Ukraine I think that it is
reasonable with some level of risk to
have that capability in the hands of the
Ukrainian Air Force by the end of this
year not in large numbers there will be
a ramp up in numbers and capabilities
but I think we'll start seeing the first
f-16s operationalized in Ukraine by the
end of this year
foreign foreign